En este video hablaremos sobre algo llamado
Teoría cinética molecular, que suena muy elegante,
pero como veremos en los próximos minutos, de
hecho nos ayuda a formarnos una idea de lo que
realmente está sucediendo con el gas, o al menos
una aproximación de lo que está sucediendo con
el gas. Primero pensemos en el tipo de cosas
que sabemos que podemos medir en un gas a un
nivel macro. Ahora, ¿qué quiero decir con macro?
Me refiero a gran escala, a una escala que es
mucho mayor que la escala de átomos o moléculas.
Y conocemos los tipos de cosas que podemos medir,
podemos medir la presión, ¿cómo lo hacemos? Bueno,
la presión es sólo la fuerza por unidad de área,
y hay varios artilugios que puedes usar para medir
la presión dependiendo de para qué lo necesites.
Puedes medir la fuerza usando resortes y aplicar
ciertas fuerzas a ciertas áreas cuadradas. Pero
todas estas son formas en las que se puede medir
la presión, y nosotros podemos medir la presión
de un gas en un recipiente. Puedes medir el
volumen de un recipiente, es bastante sencillo.
Puedes imaginar un contenedor que se parece a
esto. Y sabemos cómo encontrar el volumen de
un prisma rectangular como este, o incluso si es
una esfera o algún otro tipo de figura. Hay muchas
formas de medir el volumen sin siquiera saber
que las moléculas existen. Sabemos cómo medir
la temperatura y podemos hacerlo en diferentes
escalas, kelvin es la más usada porque es una
escala absoluta; pero puedes literalmente
usar termómetros para medir la temperatura,
y, nuevamente, puedes medir la temperatura sin
saber nada sobre átomos o moléculas. Y también
se puede medir la cantidad de una sustancia, y
en particular podemos medir la cantidad de moles.
Ahora podrías decir que los moles involucran
un cierto número de moléculas o átomos,
y sí lo hacen, pero la noción de 1 mol existía
incluso antes de que supiéramos exactamente
cuántas moléculas, cuántas partículas componían
1 mol; simplemente se veía como una cantidad de
la que se sabía que debía tener cierta cantidad de
partículas, pero no lo sabían exactamente. Así que
podemos medir todas estas cosas a un nivel macro.
Y sabemos que todo esto lo podemos conectar con la
ecuación de los gases ideales, que nos dice que
la presión multiplicada por el volumen es igual
a la cantidad de gas que tenemos. Y estamos
hablando, por supuesto, de gases ideales;
y en futuros videos veremos cómo algunos gases
se acercan a ser un gas ideal, mientras que otros
son menos ideales. Pero la cantidad que tenemos
mide el número de moles. Tenemos la constante de
los gases ideales que nos ayuda a que todas las
unidades funcionen dependiendo de las unidades
de todo lo demás, y luego tenemos la temperatura
medida en kelvin. Y mucho antes de que pudiéramos
conocer cosas como los átomos u observar átomos o
moléculas directamente, o incluso indirectamente,
los científicos pudieron establecer esta relación
utilizando estas macro medidas. ¿Pero cómo tienen
sentido estas macro medidas y su relación a nivel
molecular? De esto se trata la Teoría cinética
molecular. Dice: imagina que el gas está formado
por un montón de partículas realmente pequeñas,
esas son las moléculas de gas, y su volumen
colectivo es muy pequeño en comparación con
el volumen del contenedor, así que hay mucho
espacio vacío entre esas partículas. Ahora,
la presión es causada por estas partículas
al rebotar en los costados del contenedor,
porque en cualquier momento dado hay suficientes
partículas rebotando en los costados en cualquier
unidad de área que está produciendo una fuerza
por unidad de área está ejerciendo presión. Aquí
suponemos que estas colisiones son lo que se
conoce como elásticas, lo que veremos con mucho
más detalle en un curso de Física, pero realmente
significa que la energía cinética se conserva.
Quizás ya estés familiarizado con la idea de
que la energía cinética es igual a la mitad de
la masa multiplicada por la velocidad al cuadrado
[EC = ½ mv²] . Entonces, por la energía cinética,
al rebotar la masa de las partículas no cambia,
la masa de las partículas sigue igual; y también
decimos que la velocidad se mantiene. Entonces
tienes todas estas pequeñas partículas que,
a pesar de que su volumen colectivo es pequeño
en comparación con el volumen del contenedor,
están ejerciendo presión al tener estas colisiones
elásticas con los costados del contenedor. Y la
temperatura está relacionada proporcionalmente con
la energía cinética promedio de estas partículas:
mientras mayor sea la temperatura, mayor será
la energía cinética promedio. Ahora bien,
la energía cinética promedio es realmente
importante porque algunas de estas partículas
pueden moverse más rápido que otras y, por
supuesto, n, el número de moles, nos dice
cuántas partículas tiene el gas. Sabemos que cada
mol tiene el número de partículas de Avogadro,
así que si multiplicas los moles por el número
de Avogadro tienes el número de partículas. Y lo
que es genial de la Teoría cinética molecular que
está diseñada como una teoría es que en realidad
es lo que los químicos y físicos visualizan cuando
imaginan un gas en cualquier tipo de recipiente.
Y para que queden más claros los axiomas de la
Teoría cinética molecular o los supuestos de la
misma los muestro aquí. Y es importante que te
des cuenta de que estas son suposiciones, y que
en el mundo real existe una ligera variación;
pero estas suposiciones nos ayudan a explicar
el comportamiento de los gases. Ya mencionamos que
el gas contiene partículas en constante movimiento
aleatorio y también mencionamos que las partículas
rebotan en los costados del contenedor. El volumen
combinado de las partículas es insignificante
en comparación con el volumen total en el que
está contenido el gas. Esto es importante
al hablar de los gases ideales porque si
este volumen deja de ser insignificante, entonces
tenemos que tomar en cuenta las interacciones de
repulsión y atracción. Las partículas no ejercen
fuerzas de atracción o repulsión entre sí. Esto
se relaciona con lo que acabo de mencionar:
si tuvieran fuerzas de atracción o repulsión,
entonces tendríamos un gas que es no tan ideal.
Hablaremos de esto en otros videos. Las colisiones
entre partículas son completamente elásticas,
por lo tanto, conservan la energía cinética
y también preservarán el impulso. Y que la
energía cinética promedio de las partículas
es proporcional a la temperatura en Kelvin. Y
ya hemos hablado de eso, que la macro medición
de temperatura nos indica que es proporcional a
la energía cinética promedio de las partículas.